now unfortunately the basic form of the
functional class pattern does result in
duplicated methods as we saw with the
earlier form of the decorator pattern
the line adding dot move as a property
of car creates a brand new function
every time we invoke the car constructor
function looking at the diagram again
you can see that every instance of the
car class has its own unique version of
the move method we may prefer instead to
have it be the case that one function
object is shared across all car objects
to save memory to avoid having so many
duplicate versions of the move method
we'll need to move the code that defines
the move method outside the body of the
car constructor function in this way the
interpreter will only visit that code
one time and therefore only build one
such function to be shared across all
the instances rather than building a new
one every time we invoke a car but
notice if we have moved the definition
of the move method outside of the body
of the constructor then this function
should no longer have closure scope
access to the object is where we'd be
storing the instance of the car so if
this is off limits the move method won't
work at all how can we write this
function such that all the instances of
car could make use of it even though it
won't have access to the closure scope
that those instances were created in